[Musique]
bonsoir dernière édition de la semaine
de votre journal quotidien nous allons
faire le point sur la formation locale
de ce 6 octobre voici les principaux
titres en images la semaine bleue dédiée
aux seniors se poursuit à la verrière et
ce sont les plus jeunes qui viennent de
s'essayer à un simulateur de vieillesse
attrape la compagnie déclic théâtre
prépare la deuxième édition d'un trop
family ce sera le premier match de la
saison avec des comédiens professionnels
rendez vous samedi 8 octobre à la mairie
et puis elle la balade du goût fête ses
20 ans près de 100 fermes ouvrent leurs
portes ce week-end notamment celle de
chant garnier au porte justement tout
près de saint quentin en yvelines on
ouvre ce journal avec une bonne nouvelle
pour les utilisateurs de la piscine des
clayes-sous-bois l'établissement
salvador-allende fermée après la
découverte de traces de légionnelle dans
les canalisations des douches va pouvoir
ouvrir à nouveau ce samedi les travaux
de décontamination étant terminée est
cet équipement intercommunal ouvert en
1973 accumule néanmoins les problèmes la
découverte de bactéries dans les bassins
avant l'été et rupture d'une
canalisation en août écoutez serge
renard de l'agglomération de saint
quentin c'est au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude à la légionelle est
une bactérie qui est uniquement dans la
vapeur de l'eau des douches et
absolument pas dans les bassins donc il
n'y a aucun risque à se baigner elle est
présente de toute manière partout dans
les canalisations d'eau froide y compris
dans la dans les logements et elle n'est
absolument pas dangereuses lorsqu'elles
et but puisqu'elle est détruite par le
système digestif de l'estomac par contre
si elle est inhalée
lors d'une douche par exemple
effectivement elle peut provoquer des
maladies qui rappelle les symptômes
grippaux et qui peuvent être très graves
d'où l'intérêt pour nous évidemment
d'offrir un équipement le plus sûr
possible à la population il n'y a
absolument aucun risque dans la piscine
la piscine et chlorés on se plaint
d'ailleurs souvent de l'odeur de chlore
de la piscine mais là c'est en fait un
signe de bonne hygiène de la piscine et
effectivement il n'y a aucun risque à se
baigner et désormais il n'y a plus aucun
risque non plus à prendre des douches
puisque nous venons d'installer des
systèmes sur les douches qui bloque les
bactéries grâce à des filtres favoriser
le lien entre les générations rompre
l'isolément également des personnes
âgées cette semaine est organisée la
semaine bleue à la verrière une série
d'animations et d'ateliers prévues
jusqu'à la fin de la semaine et
notamment ce simulateur de vieillesse
vous allez le voir pour comprendre les
difficultés est des plus anciens
reportage camille lambert et nicolas
kirillovitch
marché comme une personne âgée à
seulement 13 ans l'exercice est
difficile mais relevé par idrissa dans
le cadre de la semaine bleue à la
verrière au programme un parcours et des
obstacles pour se mettre dans la peau
d'un ancien et comprendre ses
difficultés au quotidien là c'est pour
voir les handicapés comme manquer s'ils
voient les i can't stop et qu'est ce
qu'il ressent c'était difficile
parce qu'en fait ils avaient plusieurs
stades et après chaque course kavala on
devait aussi remonté son pied et son
pays il avait des points comme idrissa
les jeunes de la ville participent toute
la semaine à différentes animations
toujours en binôme avec un senior
groupes de paroles simulateur de
vieillesse ou encore goûter philo
l'objectif est de favoriser le lien
entre les générations
tout le monde a un peu peur les uns des
autres les jeunes ont un peu peur des
vieux les vieux ont peur des jeunes et
au bout du compte on n'avance pas
beaucoup alors que finalement je pense
qu'en effet un jeune qui va chercher la
baguette de pain s'il connaît que sa
voisine à l'état gèle a du mal à marcher
peut-être qui pourra penser tout seul
peut-être que madame untel elle a besoin
de pain je vais lui proposer je vais
chercher mon pain je vais lui chercher
le sien on y arrivera peut-être un jour
la semaine bleue à la verrière se
clôture vendredi soir avec la projection
du film le nouveau stagiaire une
histoire dans laquelle robert de niro
retraités décident de retourner dans du
travail entouré de jeunes collègues
après plusieurs années de discussions et
plusieurs mois de travaux le secours
populaire des yvelines à versailles
inaugure enfin c'est nouveaux locaux un
événement attendu aussi bien par les
bénéficiaires que par les bénévoles
l'ancien local était jugé trop petit
trop vétuste en d'autres termes
reportage à suivre pour mieux visiter
ses locaux qui seront inaugurés vendredi
les murs étaient entièrement recouvert
de moquette d'une moquette
orange mais sale et le plafond était pas
en marron presque noir sombre trop petit
les locaux du secours populaire de
versailles avait besoin d'un coup de
neuf après six mois de travaux les
bénévoles viennent de finir d'installer
le vestiaire un lieu aux allures de
petite boutique qui correspond mieux aux
demandes des bénéficiaires c'est très
difficile pour ces personnes est arrivée
dans un lieu qui est austère
antipathique presque insalubre c'est pas
digne ce n'est pas respectée l'oni donc
vraiment nous notre souci c'était
d'abord l'accueil un accueil plus
moderne mais aussi plus chaleureux avant
les bénéficiaires attendait sur des
chaises dans ce couloir avec l'aide de
la mairie le secours populaire s'est
doté d'un nouveau pôle alimentaire qu'il
a voulu colorée inspirée des salons de
thé
en comptant les deux locaux 113 mètres
carrés ont été entièrement refaits par
une quinzaine de bénévoles de l'antenne
toutes les peintures les enduits
l'arf et la réfection du sol on a des
projets maintenant qu'on est qu'on peut
accueillir des familles et on va on a
des projets de goûter lecture
là parmi nos bénévoles une institutrice
qui se propose de faire un jour un
atelier conte
l'inauguration officielle de ses
nouveaux locaux se tiendra vendredi 7
octobre cinq mille euros ont été
nécessaires pour réaliser ces travaux
financés par les dons la structure
s'occupe de 250 familles inscrites l'an
dernier elle a distribué trois mille
neuf cents repas
nous passons à présent à une page
culture avec la deuxième édition de
trappes impro family lancé par la
compagnie déclic théâtre et pour nous en
parler mais la nuit poquet bonsoir
mélanie sa deuxième édition de cette
opération trappe impro family et ça on
remet ça c'est pas de moi bien sûr c'est
le slogan donc de cette deuxième édition
alors samedi soir à la mairie
douze joueurs deux coaches trois
arbitres quatre musiciens amc vous allez
me dire wilfrid en fait c'est la recette
traditionnelle d'un match âpre et la
différence réside dans le titre le mieux
c'est quand même d'écouter nouvelle
yakine louise c'est le responsable du
secteur improvisation de la compagnie et
nous la présente cette soirée
les comédiens de déclic théâtre
d'aujourd'hui et d'avant et les cousins
les amis enfin les amis les cousins des
autres ligues je dirais voilà qui
viennent enrichir un petit peu notre
casting locale donc l'idée c'est d'avoir
voilà des membres des joueurs des épices
de l'équipe de trappes mais aussi des
comédiens de paris un pro de la leaf
hideux d'autres ligues parisienne et qui
sont pour beaucoup qui ont pour beaucoup
fait leurs armes un moment ou un autre
ici à trois points 50 ans et demi et
parmi ceux d'avant des noms qui parlent
hills à doumbia je pense qu'on a même
plus à le présenter de bien il a su se
faire sa place effectivement sur le plan
national saha virginie britten jennie
anne walker seront aussi présents gelé
galibert laurent mazetti révélé ce camp
et bien d'autres pas tous les noms on
laisse un peu de surprises aussi des
comédiens dont certains ont été
champions du monde ou qui le seront plus
tard on ne sait jamais d'autres qui
jouent dans des comédies musicales des
champions de bbox des champions de
france et chanteur ait de quoi faire
mélange de être discipliné de talent
forcément ce sera dinde un haut niveau
mais elle n'aurait liakine me l'a dit
c'est la réalité de leur pro qui pourra
le dire en gros tout est question d'un
point d'inspiration en fonction du thème
donné on ne sait jamais mais oui en
effet wilfried ça devrait assez vite
être sensationnel et en général le
public à la merise laurent bien aux
comédiens écoutez
l'improvisation ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on répond aussi au public que l'on
rencontre donc forcément
on s'adaptera et les gens seront
s'adapter et puis trappe c'est un peu
une capitale de l'improvisation en
france donc les gens savent que quand
ils viennent à trappes ils vont
rencontrer un public qui qui qui connaît
l'improvisation ya une vraie culture de
l'impro et du cou du coup ça ne peut
être que positive la deuxième édition de
trappes impro family rendez vous samedi
8 octobre 20h30 ce sera à la merise les
renseignements le détail sur le site
internet de la merise la mairie ce point
com merci mélanie culture toujours avec
vendredi dernier à la batterie à
guyancourt l'ouverture de la saison
c'était en présence de green s aimer
vous avez pu le découvrir brièvement
hier dans notre édition du 7 8 culture
je vous invite à des à présent à vous
rendre sur notre site internet pour
découvrir l'intégralité du reportage
consacré à ce groupe du 10 au 16 octobre
c'est la semaine du goût sept jours de
rencontres entre les professionnels de
la terre le grand public elle se clôture
à chaque année avec une balade du goût
près de saint quentin en yvelines la
ferme de gally vous accueille mais aussi
la ferme d'élevage de grandmaison à
chevreuse et puis celle de chant garnier
au mesnil saint denis où nous nous
sommes rendus
didier de nuit est agriculteur depuis
1984 avec son épouse et son beau fils il
s'occupe d'une exploitation de 190
hectares principalement ce sont des
céréales c'est à dire dans la région on
cultive surtout du blé de l'orge du maïs
est un peu d'eau les génies c'est-à-dire
colza et et féveroles cultures
céréalières mais pas seulement à la
ferme de changarnier vite un troupeau de
25 têtes dont 13 vaches allaitantes
aujourd'hui on fait un peu de
diversification plus quand on vend notre
viande
grand public un sous forme de colis et
et
de chercher leur viande à la ferme à
cacher très intéressant pour des
citadins dans la région on est très peu
on n'est plus beaucoup à faire de
l'élevage il reste encore des mohicans
qu'on va dire didier de nuit et son
épouse vous feront découvrir leurs
activités goûter les produits issus de
leur troupeau et même participer à des
balades à dos d'âne ils vous attendent
le samedi 15 et le dimanche 16 octobre
dès 10h
merci de nous avoir suivis tout au long
de la semaine c'était le dernier journal
aujourd'hui jeudi demain vendredi ce
sera l'hebdo avec nikola kirillovitch
retour sur ce qu'il ne faut pas ce qu'il
faut en retenir plutôt de l'actualité ce
qu'il ne fallait pas manquer on se
retrouvera lundi quant à nous pour un
nouveau journal très bon week end
[Musique]